grandes manoeuvres ce matin sur le web
le géant de l'internet google vient de
racheter un des sites les plus en vue en
ce moment un site de vidéos clips et
clips pardon youtube c'est un principe
simple chacun peut mettre et partager en
ligne ses clips vidéo
une idée toute bête qui viendra porter
aux fondateurs plus d'un milliard et
demi de dollars
perrine bonnet youtube si vous ne
connaissez pas déjà
c'est ça des clips des morceaux des
missions dégâts tourné en famille c'est
un gigantesque zapping à l'échelle du
monde
chaque jour sur ce site internet 100
mille vidéos de toutes sortes sont
visionner gratuitement youtube créée au
départ par quelques copains pour
s'amuser est devenu en quelques mois un
géant avec des recettes publicitaires
spectaculaire et voilà que ce géant est
racheté par un ogre google le moteur de
recherche numéro un mondial formidable
machine à fabriquer des sous google a
racheté youtube plus d'un milliard et
demi de dollars et il veut moraliser
tout ça car le risque c'est que des
pirates téléchargent sur youtube sans
aucun droit
google promet de faire le ménage il va
proposer aux maisons de disques et de
films soit de retirer les vidéos pirates
soit de les dédommager
au risque que les pionniers de youtube
trouve ce nouveau joujou un peu trop
fade et se lasse